[Music]
all right we continue to highlight
amazing educators in our district during
national teacher appreciation week today
we're focusing on a sports medicine
teacher who's a standout introducing the
field to our high schoolers
this right here these students are
learning sports medicine at southeast
tech academy from their teacher
alexandra forshee the kids start in my
program their freshman year and i have
the opportunity to have them every year
from freshman to senior year during
those four years she teaches them to
diagnose rehab and get people back to
physical activity this year one of the
things that has really been the
highlight is because of the pandemic and
the way school was last year the
students coming back and just being so
excited to do everything related to our
subject principal ryan cordia says 4 she
makes sure these students get an
internship their senior year and
prepares them for their future she just
really created a pathway that shortens
the timeline from high school graduation
to getting paid as a professional and
her kids are lucky to have her and we're
lucky to have her here at southeast they
wanted to choose someone that they felt
really worked with the kids kind of
outside the box and so they felt like i
was a really good choice for that
because of what i do
with especially my seniors in the sports
medicine program and getting them the
ability to be able to go out to medical
facilities and be able to observe
medical professionals and real patients
and how that whole process
goes just knowing i've had a little
piece of that puzzle to hopefully you
know see them one day working as a
medical professional is very rewarding